hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast a keynote presentation
molecular mechanisms of gene X
environment interactions possible
relevance for prevention diagnosis and
treatment of psychiatric disorders it is
presented by Elizabeth bender PhD
director of the Max Planck Institute of
Psychiatry I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I will be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box it
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. bender I will
now turn the presentation over to her
okay thank you very much I'm very happy
to present some of our work in which we
try to elucidate molecular mechanisms of
gene by stress interactions in order to
get a better understanding of the
pathophysiology of psychiatric disorders
maybe design a novel treatment and
prevention and strategies so the risk
for developing psychiatric disorders is
influenced by both genetic risk as well
as environmental stressors and these
are especially impactful what happening
early on as early as during pregnancy
uterine but also during infancy and
childhood these stressors dramatically
increase the risk for individuals to
suffer of psychiatric disorders later in
life
however after experiencing such adverse
life events thought everybody actually
follows a risk detective trajectory but
there are individuals who actually
remain resilient to deserve our adverse
life events so in my presentation I
would like to present two main things
one is that this long-term embedding of
risk after being exposed to first life
events can actually be mediated by
epigenetic mechanisms and the second is
how genetic factors could actually
moderate this embedding of risk in my
talk I will actually focus on one system
that I think is critical as an interface
between the environment and the organism
and this is the stress hormone system
when we're faced with a threat the
system is actually activated and leads
to the release of ACTH from the
pituitary that then actually stimulates
the adrenal gland to release Google
corticoids the main glucocorticoid in
humans being cortisol cortisol actually
prepares the body for a fight-or-flight
response and to actually be able to cope
with the stressor it is a hormone that
reaches all tissues in the body what is
important about the system is that not
only does it react to stress but it's
also the main system that actually shuts
down the stress response after the
threat is over and this happens via
negative feedback mechanisms at several
brain levels that actually shut down the
activation of this axis so an important
system at the interface between the
environment and our body and is
actually this balance between activation
and inhibition is often disturbed in
psychiatric disorders a second reason
for why I think the system is especially
important to look at in the context of
gene-environment interactions is that
the main receptor for the stress hormone
the glucocorticoid receptor is actually
a nuclear receptor that translocates to
the nucleus and binds to specific
elements at the DNA to agender a
transcriptome wide response to stress so
the article recording quick receptor
stress can actually have lasting effects
on the cellular response and this could
be moderated by genetic variation so the
question is how can kinetic factors
environmental factors actually converge
on specific genomic elements to convey
mechanisms of gene and environment
interactions and for this I'd like to
point out the response elements that are
just highlighted forward a
glucocorticoid receptor is binding term
GRE here in this picture and
glucocorticoid response elements can
actually enhance our suppress
transcriptional responses with the
activation of the glucocorticoid
receptor and the binding to this
response element not only is the
transcriptional landscape changing but
these receptors can also end gender a
local epigenetic response they do
actually lead to changes that open the
chromatin by inducing histone
modifications but they're also reducing
the DNA methylation content at these
sites so that with a prior activation of
these of this receptor and binding to
the response elements one can actually
alter the set point for the future
transcriptional response in addition to
the environment being able to impact on
the transcript
a response but also on the epigenetic
landscape of the target genes genetic
variation can actually also possibly
moderate how glucocorticoid response
elements actually moderate both the
transcriptional response but also the
epigenetic response so I in this talk I
would like to give you some examples of
how such interactions of genetic
variation environmental variation can
actually to changes in gene expression
also real changes in epigenetics and I
would first like to highlight an example
of how stress can actually lead directly
to changes in the epigenome and for this
we actually looked at a cell model we
used a multipotent human hippocampal
progenitor cell line derived from a
human 11 week old fetus and this cell
line can actually differentiate into
adult urine it expresses synaptic
markers prior publications have proven
that glucocorticoids or stress hormone
is actually effective and impacting
these progenitor cell lines and when we
map the gene expression profile of these
human progenitor cell lines we actually
see that the cluster with gene
expression profiles from fetal brain
tissue from 16 to 21 post conception
weeks so they actually a possible model
for what's happening to the brain during
pregnancy and as I said before pregnancy
is a time point during development where
there a lot of environmental impacts can
have lasting effects so what we wanted
to understand here is where a
glucocorticoid receptor activation can
actually induce changes in DNA
methylation that indeed evoke ample
neurons while they're undergoing
neurogenesis and then to actually also
understand whether such
epigenetic alterations could indeed
relate to the long lasting effects it
used for early life stress exposure in
humans so in our model we treated these
hippocampal progenitor cells at
different stages during that development
so we treated them early on during the
proliferation stage but also while they
were differentiating and then harvested
Amla cells but what we also wanted to
know is what happens if we treat them
early during proliferation and
differentiation and then actually leave
them alone
untreated for another three weeks to
understand lasting effects and this is
depicted in the third pictogram and we
also wanted to understand whether the
timing of the treatment with
glucocorticoids matters is it early on
during proliferation and differentiation
or after differentiation that actually
matters for these epigenetic changes and
this is depicted in the last pictogram
and so we harvested the cells at these
four different treatment time points and
then we measured genome-wide DNA
methylation as well as RNA expression
using Illumina array technology so we
first wanted to know do our different
treatments actually lead to differences
in gene expression so do cloaca
corticoids
change the transcriptional landscape and
this is depicted here in this in this in
this first slide here where you can see
that the most changes in gene expression
actually happen when we treat doing
proliferation of proliferation and
differentiation and the amount of
transcriptional changes goals
dramatically down after the washout so
we find over five-and-a-half transcripts
that are significantly changed after
correction for multiple testing across
all these four time points when we look
at DNA methylation we again see that
reading during the pro
phrasing stage actually leads to the
largest amount of changes in methylation
overall we do see close to 30,000 DNA
methylation sites to be changed
significantly and these changes go down
in the other treatment time points but
what is interesting that there seems to
be a divergence of gene expression
changes and methylation changes when we
treat the cells early and then leave
them alone for 20 days after this war
short periods well we have relatively
low numbers of gene expression changes
but quite substantial changes in DNA
methylation and so we were very
interested in really understanding
dynamics all the changes in gene
expression as well as DNA methylation so
what we did first is we looked at the
changes of DNA methylation across these
different treatment time points and we
looked at all the ones that had
significant changes evolve an even more
strict cutoff than I just showing before
and we observed that the changes in DNA
methylation actually clustered in four
distinct trajectories so we had for
example the Queen trajectories where
CPGs actually had reduced methylation
although differentiation laws of the
cells but with the treatment there was
also always a bit higher methylation and
then there was an opposite pattern with
the increasing methylation with
differentiation were the dexamethasone
of glucocorticoid treated cells actually
had lower methylation levels across the
whole trajectory here and then there
were projector ease that were not
affected by the differentiation of the
cells but just affected by the exome
Amazon itself what was interesting when
we tried to find which pathways were
enriched among these different
trajectories we found that that green
and the red trajectory actually enriched
four pathways relevant for cell
proliferation and differentiation and
developmental processes
whereas the more stable trajectories
especially the trajectory with the most
pronounced glucocorticoid effects
actually were irrelevant also for
transcription and regulation of
transcription which makes sense as a
Google quoting quit receptor is actually
a strong transcriptional regulator next
to the pathway enrichment I'm actually
so showing some examples of specific
trajectories of DNA methylation of
candidate methylation sites and genes
where you can see that a pattern of
increased methylation is mostly followed
by the pattern of decreased mRNA
expression over time so that we have a
concerted change for some of these
between DNA methylation and mRNA
expression what is interesting but maybe
a bit more difficult to see is that at
the last time point when we treat after
differentiation and have the mark up
here there is actually relatively little
changes in both DNA methylation and gene
expression and this is illustrated in
more detail here for one candidate gene
that we looked at and you can see that
on the upper panel the DNA methylation
actually is dramatically reduced with
proliferation recruitment proliferation
differentiation treatment and stays on
demethylated after the washout but these
this demethylation is actually not
happening when the cells are treated
when they're already differentiated so
there seems to be a developmental window
that is important for when the treatment
is happening to cause these epigenetic
changes and what is also important that
we do see is the gene expression changes
concur with early time points but our
absence with the quite dramatic changes
in DNA methylation after the washout
period has already showed before across
all the changes that we actually
observed so I really want to focus on
this finding that you have quite
profound and lasting changes in DNA
methylation that are not accompanied by
changes in gene expression at baseline
so we wanted to look at this in a bit
more detail and we actually took the
locus of this fkbp5 gene and use
targeted bisulfite sequencing to find
Matt the glucocorticoid response element
in this locus and they're actually quite
a few glucocorticoid response elements
that are distributed in the proximal
enhancers as well as the entry and so I
would like to give you an example of two
in chronic glucocorticoid response
elements and I'm showing each individual
CPG within these glucocorticoid response
elements and the methylation level and
after vehicle or dexamethasone treatment
and what you can see is that each CPG
within that glucocorticoid response
element actually shows this quite
dramatic and lasting change in DNA
methylation so when we aggregate the
finding across on all Google cortical
response elements we do find that these
elements actually are quite methylated
initially and you can also see in the
lowest panel that the reduction in
methylation actually seems to center
right around the actually predicted
motif for the binding for the
glucocorticoid receptor suggesting
that's actually active binding of the
receptor that leads to these changes in
DNA methylation and it has been proposed
that specific DNA repair mechanisms
together with hydroxy methylation
changes could contribute to this active
demethylation so I have shown you that
Google corticoid receptor treatment at
specific development
ages can lead to lasting effects on the
epigenome with lasting decreases in DNA
methylation but that this is not
followed by basal changes in gene
expression what we have shown before is
that changes in methylation of these
glucocorticoid response elements it's
not associate with baseline changes but
changes the set point for activations by
glucocorticoids so that in the D
methylated version or unmethylated
person when introducing this element in
a reporter gene a say and this is
depicted in the white box plot you can
actually see a stronger enhancement of
transcription that when you insert a
methylated version of this Google
quality code response element in in the
vector so that one could actually
proposed that this demethylation while
not leading to basal changes would alter
the set point for future activations
with glucocorticoids and what we wanted
to explore is whether these early
treatments or early exponents to the
stress hormone could actually lead to
POY states that would alter the set
point all the organisms to future stress
explosions and for this we first wanted
to know where we actually have these
changes in DNA methylation and for this
we looked at mapping the changes in DNA
methylation to the chrome age and M
annotation of the roadmap epigenomics
process where the sites or regions in
the genome are annotated for their
function in being for example an active
transcription start site or an enhancer
that can be active or weak so we
actually annotated or looked were there
any of our changes at the different
points would be enriched for specific
enhancer element and what we observe is
that the changes that happened during
the proliferation phase are enriched for
changes in active transcription with
which would actually make sense since
these are cells that are actively
replicated the second enrichment we saw
were the changes that happened in both
the proliferation and differentiation
face but also remained after the walk
showed were enriched both in enhancers
but also in glucocorticoid response
elements sort of confirming that we get
direct in fact of the glucocorticoid
scepter and the response elements and
then we're also changing enhancer
function but what was most interesting
is that there was a subset of regulatory
elements that were only enriched in
those sites that changed only after or
only significantly changed after the
washout period and these were actually
bivalent or poise transcription site or
bivalent enhancers again confirming that
these lasting changes could be very
important in non regulating based LAN
transcription but their reactivity to
subsequent exposures and so this we
wanted to test with an additional
experiment and so we repeated the
experiment I just showed you before but
we added after the washout an acute
stimulation with glucocorticoids with
the lower dose and so what we did see is
that when the cells were treated in
vehicles throughout and then had an
active stimulation we saw some changes
in gene expression and this is depicted
in the box plots in yellow when we
treated the cells with exome medicine
and then did not stimulate there was not
a strong change in gene expression but
when they were actually treated early on
then had the wash out and then
we stimulated the extent of the
transcriptional change which was larger
than if they were just treated with an
acute stimulation of dexamethasone but
did not have this chronic treatment
before again suggesting that we poised
the cells to react differently to a
second exposure to the stress hormone so
these were all data that we gathered in
a Cell on a human cell and human fetal
cell and our question was would the
changes that we observe actually relate
to changes that we observed in humans
that are exposed to actual adverse life
events and not just glucocorticoids and
so we first collaborated with McGill in
Canada who have generated datasets from
human post-mortem hippocampus of
individuals who either died by suicide
or control individuals or individuals
who died of suicide but also had
documented exposure to type child abuse
I'm during their early years and what we
did see is that and find a strong
enrichment of the methylation sites the
change in our cell model among the
methylation sites that are also
different between control individuals
and individuals Rita died of a suicide
and even more pronounced is to die by
suicide and it had been exposed to child
abuse suggesting that there is at least
some relevance all the findings of the
hippocampal progenitor cell model to
human post-mortem hippocampus and
glucocorticoid exposure to exposure to
child abuse since there are many more
datasets to explore the same question of
changes in DNA methylation after
exposure to child abuse in peripheral
tissues so there's proof above we also
wanted to understand whether there are
some avila with data from peripheral
blood here and what we did see is that
in two independent studies that observed
DNA methylation
changes in adults exposed to child abuse
we saw that there was actually also an
enrichment of our sites in the
peripheral blood data suggesting that
since coca-cola crates
reach all tissues in the whole body
there might be some cross Russia
relevance of these effects and this
might be used for biomarkers in the
future so to summarize this part of the
talk stress actually changes gene
expression but stress also after these
changes in gene expression has subsided
can leave lasting epigenetic changes so
it changes the epigenetic setpoint and
with a second exposure to stress these
changes in set point could actually
contribute to change trajectories to
either risk or resilience to psychiatric
disorders so understanding how the set
points are changing could actually help
us understand to prevent psychiatric
disorders so I've shown you this picture
before of genetic variation epigenetic
changes and gene expression changes and
how these are orchestrating our
responses to stress and I now want to
show you how to net evaluation can
actually alter our gene expression
responses facts and how that may
contribute to risk for psychiatric
disorders so we wanted to explore such
expression quantitative trait loci and
usually what you mean when you say
expression quantitative trait loci are
genetic variants that change the amount
of basal RNA transcription and we were
not interested in basal RNA
transcription but what we were
interested in was RNA transcription
changes after stimulation with gluten
cortically so basically we're interested
in scenarios were that you
berry-berry and does not necessarily
inflate Spaceland transcription as
depicted in the reddish box pot but
actually changed a significantly the
extent to which gene expression is
changing after stimulation with
glucocorticoid zeal and to assess this
who actually did an experiment where we
used hundred and sixty male individuals
we took their blood a baseline extracted
both DNA and RNA and we then gave them
or the court acquits and then measured
the gene expression in preferred but
again three hours later and with the DNA
we measured genome-wide snip variation
and with the RNA we measured gene
expression both the baseline as well as
after the stimulation and what we wanted
to understand is are there genetic
variants that actually moderate the
local change in gene expression after
glucocorticoids and when we ran this
analysis we actually identified close to
4,000 eqtls meaning 3600 snips that
moderate the extent of change of close
to 300 transcripts after glucocorticoids
and most of them fell in this pattern
that I showed before with very little
changes the baseline but prominent
genetic impact on the stimulated gene
expression so we wanted to understand
what are these snips that have little
impact on basement and description but
actually change the transcription after
basically a mediator of the environment
and what we found is that the these
genetic variants that alter the
transcriptional response to stimulation
for stress stimulation are actually much
more distant from the transcript than
genetic variants that influence baseline
gene transcription we also found that
this long range for Galatia
and could be mediated by changes in the
3d structure so we found the rect
rahmatan interactions on this website
with the transcription start site both
by genome-wide and targeted approaches
we saw that the snip sites were actually
enriched for binding sites using
chromatin in moon mr. chemistry present
precipitation with the glucocorticoid
receptor but also for predicted
transcription factor col factors for the
glucocorticoid receptor and what we also
found is that these snip regions are
actually enriched in enhancers not only
of peripheral blood but also of the
brain this would suggest that there are
snips that alter the genomic response to
stress they seem to be distinct from
snips that alter baseband transcription
and so the next question was do these
snips actually increase the risk for
stress-related disorders such as
depression for example so together that
question we used genome-wide Association
snip Association data for major
depression and back when we ran this
study there was no Gina whites there
were lost genome-wide significant hits
for major depression so far so we had to
assume that there were some two genetic
years in the nominally significant
associations and our question was would
our functional snips be more often than
chance be represented among the
nominally significant snips associated
with major depression and this is what
we wanted to find out here so we first
looked at the expected number of your
random snips or snips that influenced
baseline transcription with snakes that
are associated at nominal significant
level with major depression and these
are the distribution in blue and in
light gray and then we tested that
compared to the actual
number of slips that overlap which is
actually this arrow and found that never
did a random distribution reach the
actual number of overlapping step
suggesting that there is enrichment of
our glucocorticoid response East nips
among snips associated with major
depression so we next wanted to confirm
this association with depression in an
independent sample and for this we took
the overlap between our fun concepts and
the snips associated with depression a
large G was and actually looked at snips
that would uniquely identify this
overlap and summed the number of risk
allele in this overlap and we calculated
at some of these risk alleles in an
independent sample of depression cases
and controls and what we found is that
there was a significant shift in the
distribution of these risk allele sound
scores in cases with depression so that
they had slightly higher numbers of
these risk alleles than controls
confirming again some Association of
these variants with major depression so
since these snips actually react to
glucocorticoids wanted to know whether
these associations would actually be
unmasked especially under conditions of
early adversity and so we this looked at
another cohort where we actually had
information of adversity during
childhood so we had individuals with
high adversity and depicted the red line
medium adversity the Green Line and
lower adversity in childhood in the blue
line and then we looked at their genetic
stress profile score and whether it
predicted mood and anxiety disorder and
what we saw is that the genetic profile
score actually only predicted risk for
mood and anxiety disorder when these
individuals were exposed to high levels
of early adversity suggesting that he
risked
the properties of these snips are only
unmasked when individuals are exposed to
stress early in life in the term of gene
environment interactions so these snips
actually not only seem to predict mood
and anxiety disorders but also
associated with end of phenotypes
associated with the stress response in
the brain for example like amygdala
reactivity to threat or cortisol
reactivity to mental stress so I have
shown you that there are genetic
variants that alter the first
transcriptome response to stress within
a few hours his lip seems to moderate
neurocircuits response to threat and
also risk for mood and anxiety disorders
so the question is that trauma and
stress is not only a risk factor for
depression but also for a range of other
psychiatric disorders so we wanted to
know whether maybe our snips are also
enriched in genome-wide Association
studies for other psychiatric disorders
and we saw a strong enrichment also in
snips associated with schizophrenia who
which which is also exacerbated by
exposure to early adversity and what is
interesting is that seem to be a number
of functional genetic variants that are
responsive to stress that are associated
not only to depression but also
schizophrenia and even bipolar disorder
suggesting that there is a cross
disorder type of risk that could be
conveyed by these stress sensitivity
genetic variance so an enhanced res
mourner ability without disease
specificity so I talked a lot about the
genetic variance but what about the
transcripts the very influencing what
was interesting is that when we take all
the transcripts that are influenced by
genetic bearings that alter their
responsibility to stress and
associated with either depression or
schizophrenia I actually found a highly
co-expressed network of transcripts that
actually shows enrichment for specific
pathways that have been related to
psychiatric disorders as well as stress
such as endocytosis that's important for
neuronal signaling as well as
cytoplasmic ribosomal proteins so a
network of transcripts that are
co-expressed and Co regulated by stress
a glucocorticoid responsive
co-expression network and so we wanted
to understand whether this Court's
pression network of transcripts would
actually be affected by exposures to
different social experience both
positive as well as negative and for
this we actually used an animal model
that combines positive early experiences
such as early handling or negative
experiences so this limiting nesting
material and then these animals would
either positive or negative early
experiences are then randomized again in
either having a positive adult social
experience being housed together it
wouldn't overact remise female or
experiencing chronic social defeat
stress over a certain amount of time so
we have conditions of animals receiving
positive environment throughout their
lives or negative environment throughout
their life or having mixed environments
and then we look at different brain
regions that are important for stress
regulation and actually tested the gene
expression all of these over 60 are
transcripts that actually have 55 miles
orthologues using targeted RNA sequence
and so what we did observe is that there
were some but not very strong main
effects on gene expression but was was
more pronounced is that the quartz
pressure
work pattern actually change with the
different types of social exposure the
combination of positive versus negative
but we know that is that in the
paraventricular nucleus we actually saw
that there was a strong network
structure of these genes in a positive
social environment and enriched early
environment and this network structure
disappeared with exposure to stress and
the network structure was not present
with positive environment in the bento
ca1 a part of the hippocampus but
actually seemed to emerge in stressful
conditions so in the absence of strong
main effects that seem to be so
suppressed dependent changes in network
properties in a brain region specific
way so this is another way to look at
that how the network properties actually
change with the brain region as well as
the different stress conditions and so
the first thing we know that is that the
network structure was actually closest
for the hypothalamus Department trickle
and nucleus for the enriched early
environment so being very close together
the second thing we noted that there
were how genes or central genes for the
more common for both the low stress
condition in the hypothalamus as well as
the highest stress condition in the
hippocampus suggesting that there are
concert that changes all these networks
across different brain regions and
different conditions so there seem to be
sheer central Network genes all the two
brain regions and the two environments
and this like here depicts the network
in the hypothalamus with early
enrichment where we have this strong and
networks and highlighted are specific
central genes then appear both in the
parent Ricola nucleus for the early
enrichment as well as the ventral
hippocampus for the
stressful on life stressful environments
so this suggests that there are snips
that alter the first transcriptome
response to stress that moderate
neurocircuits response to threat which
leads to an increased risk for mood and
anxiety disorder and the question is now
that we think that these snips actually
alter the core regulation all stress
response networks and thereby a circuit
function that predisposes to is for
psychiatric disorders so just very
quickly I showed you that stress can
change or can be moderated I'll have it
to affect moderated on gene expression
and this was on a peripheral blood with
some relevance for the brain and that
stress can also directly impact DNA
methylation properties of neurons and
when we actually combine these two
datasets
what is quite interesting that we get a
strong overlap all of the sites that
role is changing the methylation and the
snip sites actually moderate at the
glucocorticoid induced response so there
is an overlap of genetic as well as
epigenetic risks that actually come
together and it could further contribute
to these gene environment interactions
so in the end I'll show you some very
specific examples of how genes and
environment can actually interact and
pick specific examples for the genome
looking within single nucleotide
polymorphisms and of the epigenome only
focusing on DNA methylation but it needs
to be acknowledged that there are many
layers on the epigenetic side as well as
the genetic side and also the proteome
site that were not mentioned I also
wanted to convey that stress early in
development can actually lead to
alterations of lifelong risk or
resilience trajectories possibly by
leading to change
in epigenetic regular in the epigenome
of regulators or enhancers of stress
responsive genes they were changing the
setpoint and for future stress responses
the question is now why would we care
can this actually lead us to important
insights for the clinic and we actually
have identified a candidate that is
regulated in that manner that is called
fkbp5 where early exposures leads to an
epigenetic repression and that is
associated with future risk for
psychiatric disorders and this molecule
can be targeted by small molecule
antagonists and in animal models this
seems to have a stress-reducing effect
in animals and so could be a possible
strategy to improve resilience in
individuals exposed to it and with this
I would like to end my presentation and
thank a large number of co-workers and
collaborators worldwide thank you very
much thank you dr. bender for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click the
send button or speaker we'll follow up
with your questions via email so let's
get started our first question is what
is the presumed mechanism of how
glucocorticoid receptor activation leads
to epigenetic changes yeah this is a
very important question I think they're
they're they're two different sets of
mechanisms that can contribute to that
one is actually the glucocorticoid
receptor binding to the response
elements in the DNA and leading to local
acts
demethylation and here some papers have
proposed involvement of DNA repair
mechanisms and maybe also of introducing
intermediate steps such as hydroxy
methylation via the 1011 enzyme family
but this has not been truth yet and is
under current exploration so and
receptor-mediated active demethylation
the other post the other effects that we
do see seem to be indirect effects that
may be mediated by by by genes that are
activated or repressed by
glucocorticoids that then in turn could
lead to changes in the epigenome thank
you
next one is to polygenic risk scores for
psychiatric disorders interact with
early adversity to predict risk yeah
again a very important question also
with the now ever increasing any number
of genome-wide Association studies that
we do have for psychiatric disorders and
the knowledge that both genes and
environment contribute they actually
have been quite a number of studies that
have explored how polygenic risk from
these case control she was and would
actually interact with environmental
risk factors and there are different
findings for example the polygenic risk
or for major depression does seem to
have additive effects but not to
interact with early adversity whereas
for example the polygenic risk or for
schizophrenia seems to moderate the
impact of obstetric complications on the
risk to develop schizophrenia and
further on so what is important is that
we need to look at these genome-wide
Association study polygenic ways course
but also to maybe explore other
functional and polygenic scores like I
showed in my presentation where we look
at or have a
more funnel hypothesis about snips that
moderate the stress hormone receptor
impact whether these would actually then
attract you think he looks like we have
time for one more question could we
develop biomarkers for prevention using
these approaches yes so this is again an
important question and often epigenetic
profiles are distinct between different
tissues that means that the brain and
the blood and what we do observe is that
glucocorticoid activation actually leads
to some extent overlapping changes in
blood and brain and so that may be
changes of DNA methylation pattern in
prefer blood could serve as a Sentinel
for what is happening in other tissues
including the brain and so I think
understanding how different impacts both
genetic as well as environmental impact
on the epigenome in a cross tissue
manner can actually also help us to
develop better biomarkers for
stress-related leads I would like to
once again thank dr. bender for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December 27th 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that is
all for now thank you for joining us we
hope to see you again soon goodbye